they have a flag but they do not have a
nation that's what the independence
referendum was about the billboards are
still up but the euphoria about the
quest for independence in Iraqi
Kurdistan has subsided he is rising
concern over isolation by Iraq and
neighbouring countries we just entered
the Iraqi Kurdistan through Turkey but
the big question is just how long this
water will remain open
the Turkish government says it could
shut it at any time they say they fear
an independent Kurdish state could
increase separatist tension in Turkey as
well Iraq's central government in
Baghdad has caught international air
links to Erbil so it's not possible to
fly there now we have to drive to the
capital city of the Kurdistan region on
the way we come upon this market which
is usually buzzing but clashes between
Iraqi forces and Kurdish Peshmerga
fighters since the referendum have kept
people away standing my abaddon camera
is superbly random I am eligible
maleta why Sir Bob Uecker happy I'm
electable random necklace random a right
to have a nation what does that mean we
are about to meet someone who helped
organize the referendum re mum shine he
invites us for Kurdish lunch to talk
about his struggle for identity this is
a very typical Kurdish me right Yara
what does it mean to you it means our
survival means our very culture and we
have to protect it as you are protecting
our self physical being because without
the food we won't have a culture and
without the culture there won't be
accreditation during our conversation
our II can't stop himself from following
the news about the conflict the fighting
of a territory and oil for re it's a
story of being oppressed for generations
I learned to be Kurdish when I was in my
mother's WAMP because her brother and
her
nephew's were missing as part of the
genocide she was displaced when I was in
her bomb womp
that's when I have been inheriting the
Kurdish identity he tells me about his
family being displaced during Saddam
Hussein's rule about the gas attack in
the 80s against Kurds
re-sod he hates being called Iraqi it's
very offensive it's very humiliating to
hold an Iraqi passport as a Kurdish
people I feel like I'm being humiliated
every single time when I put it into my
pocket or into my back ari says he wants
to fight for Kurdish form of nationalism
that is civic and inclusive of different
ethnicities unlike the brand of
nationalism in neighboring countries he
says but is an independent Kurdish state
the proper solution to more identity
opinions vary you are smart is an
analyst of the Iraqi Kurdish conflict
like most people he voted yes in the
referendum but the conflict growing in
Iraq in no fears that Kurdish
nationalism could be used for negative
sense what we really fear is that this
crisis turns Kurdish nationalism into
something that can create problems
between the people this street was the
street where everybody used to meet
Kurds Arabs Turkmen everybody they would
come here for a meal but nowadays since
the crisis less and less Arabs are
coming the question is how the Kurdish
regional government will capitalize on
growing nationalist sentiment in the
Middle East
the balance of power can change fast
you